[Music]
Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harowitz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy what if World War II had been
reported the way the establishment media
writes about the global Jihad today the
question is pertinent in light of the
ongoing demonization of President
Trump's adviser step K Bannon who was
recently vilified by The Establishment
media for for a 10-year-old unproduced
film Project discussing the Jihad threat
Mata gold of the Washington Post
described the film in lurid terms she
said the flag fluttering above the US
capital is emblazoned with a crescent
and star chance of ALU Akbar rise from
inside the building that's the
provocative opening scene of a
documentary style movie outlined 10
years ago by Steven K Bannon that
envisioned radical Muslims taking over
the country and remaking it into the
Islamic States of America according to a
document describing the project obtained
by The Washington Post hate mongering
fearmongering am I right well Matea gold
didn't bother to ask Omar akmed what he
thought about this ammed was the
co-founder and longtime board chairman
of the counil on American Islamic
relations or care and he once said Islam
isn't in America to be equal to any
other Faith but to become dominant the
Quran the Muslim book of scripture
should be the highest Authority in
America and Islam the only except Ed
religion on earth akmed now denies
saying those words but the original
reporter still stands by her story and
Care spokesman Ibrahim Hooper once said
I wouldn't want to create the impression
that I wouldn't like the government of
the United States to be Islamic sometime
in the future so said honest EB
meanwhile according to a captured
internal document the Muslim Brotherhood
to which all major Muslim groups in the
US are linked is dedicated to in its own
words eliminating and destroying Western
Civilization from from within and
sabotaging its miserable house so that
it falls and Allah's religion is
Victorious over other religions then
there's Abu Musa the Washington DC Imam
who said several years ago that he wants
to establish an Islamic State of America
by the year
2050 Mata gold mentions none of this
Steve Bannon is the one who actually did
his homework and for this he is
described as a bigoted
islamophobe gold also says the proposal
names two conservative writers and
terrorism experts who could serve as
potential onscreen guests including
Robert Spencer director of the gadat
website who is labeled by the Southern
Poverty Law Center as an anti-muslim
propagandist am I now now imagine if
this were 1930 and the Southern Poverty
Law Center existed and it issued a
lavishly Illustrated meticulously
documented report on critics of the
Nazis dubbing them anti-german
propagandists or anti-german hate group
leaders the lavish publication would
include profiles of Winston Churchill
journalist Edgar Mauer and other early
critics of Hitler noting that when each
had made false claims about Hitler false
that is according to the Nazis and
charging them with hate and anti-german
bias imagine if the mainstream media
whenever it quoted Churchill maer or the
others described them as anti-german and
noted that the Southern Poverty Law
Center said they were anti-german
propagandists and ha group leaders they
would call them Rabel rousers and
demagogues quotes from Geral and Garing
would invariably be included calmly
explaining the truth and patiently
answering questions about what a shame
it was that they had to deal with the
likes of Churchill and other hate
mongers this kind of coverage would be
Universal critics of Nazism would never
be described in the mainstream media in
anything but pejorative terms whenever
they receive media attention they would
be challenged to respond to charges that
they were anti-german and spreading hate
their views would more often be
presented by the splc itself and others
who dubbed them anti-german more often
then they themselves would get a chance
to explain themselves the leading
authorities the media consulted about
Hitler and Nazism would be favorable to
both and opposed only to excessive
Violence by the brown shirts which they
describe as inconsistent with the spirit
of Nazism meanwhile the critics would be
constantly vilified ridiculed likened to
the Klux Clan and other genuinely
hateful groups groups people would write
that they wanted to attack them
physically and that it would be
legitimate to do so imagine that this
situation prevailed without any cracks
in the edifice for 5 years 10 years 15
years imagine that it prevailed as
Hitler came to power as he began
persecuting the Jews as he began his
rearmament of Germany as he bullied weak
Western leaders who were anxious to
appease him anyway into allowing him to
take Austria and Czechoslovakia and
finally as he invaded Poland and the
Western Powers finally decided to fight
back imagine that every step Britain
France and ultimately the Soviet Union
and the United States took to defend
themselves against Hitler and the Nazis
was decried by the establishment media
and a huge segment of the American
public as anti-german as a manifestation
of hatred and bigotry imagine if every
step FDR took to prosecute the war was
denounced and even voided by federal
court orders if and he was derided as a
fool a criminal an authoritarian ruler
and there were open calls not only for
his impeachment but for a coup to remove
him from power and even numerous calls
for his
assassination in that scenario which
side do you think would have won the war
I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]